it's Christmassy who knows what might  happen  [Music]  this time has been difficult for all of  us but Christmas comes we must do our  best to enjoy it I won't enjoy anything  right now  [Music]  your mother was a cleverest inventor I  ever knew and there was never any doubt  when I asked what our greatest creation  was you  [Music]  your mother created our world I have a  meeting with this  she was not queen that's our service  princess Farah the beauty of the realms  lies with you be careful who you trust  I've been expecting you  mother ginger wants to move around  I'm going to fix me healthy it's time to  save the kingdom  don't destroy everything my mother read  are you ready  [Music]  me  you